well I my relationship with Carnegie
Mellon goes way back 30 years with a
remarkable group of people here that
formed this company called three rivers
so I was aware of the strength of the
school for many years ago in fact it was
Raj ready here who was the one that
pointed Lucasfilm out to where I was
then I knew Randy Pausch before he was a
CMU so here was a guy that with this
incredible energy and intensity and of
course he came to see him you it and in
setting up the program here we talked a
fair amount about the process and what
it means to have a creative environment
and it's one of the things I remember
most about Randy were the discussions
about the environment that is the
creative environment I think that when
it comes to creativity that the tentacle
people and the artists are actually the
same they're both involved in creative
activities the fact that it's art of
technology doesn't matter when you put
them together there's a multiplication
effect that takes place the whole is
really much greater than the sum of the
parts and there's something about that
inspiration that takes place in fact the
term we use is that art inspires
technology and technology inspires the
art and when they're working close
collaboration both of them grow as a
result of it and they grow in surprising
ways and you can't even predict it it's
clear to me that CMU has this unique
combination of the best in computer
science the best in computer graphics
the best in entertainment technology the
best in robotics there isn't any other
place where they've got that combination
together and students interacting with
each other and the result of that is
this dynamic that creates a new kind of
person that's that's in a position to
address the unpredictable things that
are coming there imprintable because
they make them happen